Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
(Bruit de vagues)
Imaginez ce paysage sonore -
on peut imaginer un son -
imaginez ce paysage sonore.
Moi, ça me fait penser à mon village,
chez moi, en Bretagne.
Imaginez les petits bateaux de pêche, les
falaises, le granit, les petites criques,
les oiseaux de mer, les cormorans,
les fous de Bassan.
Et bien sûr l'océan et les vagues.
Vous l'avez compris, je suis venu
pour vous parler de vagues.
Je suis moi-même surfeur et explorateur,
c’est ma spécialité.
Je voyage à la recherche
de nouveaux spots de surf.
Et pour vous parler de vagues, je vais
commencer par vous montrer quatre photos
qui sont juste là.
Tout d’abord,
vous avez Justine Dupont, célèbre surfeuse
française qui surfe des vagues géantes.
Vous avez l’Empereur
de Chine au 13ᵉ siècle.
Vous avez une embarcation
traditionnelle au Pérou
et un autoportrait de Paul Gauguin.
Je vais vous poser une question :
d’après vous, quel est le lien
entre ces quatre photos ?
Évidemment, il y a
plusieurs liens possibles.
Il y a un lien que je veux mettre
en avant aujourd’hui pour vous,
c’est l’hydrodiversité.
Vous connaissez tous la biodiversité :
c’est la variété des espèces
animales et végétales,
les êtres vivants d’une manière générale.
Mais les vagues ne sont pas incluses
dans cette notion.
On dit que les vagues viennent mourir sur
la plage comme si elles étaient vivantes.
Elles ne sont pas vivantes,
mais mouvantes.
Elles hébergent la vie, mais ne sont
pas considérées dans la biodiversité.
L’hydrodiversité est là
pour compléter cette notion.
L’hydrodiversité, c’est la variété des
milieux aquatiques en mouvement.
Par exemple dans une rivière,
ça va être une cascade,
des torrents, des rapides.
Dans les océans, ce qu’il y a
de plus dynamique, ce sont les vagues.
L’hydrodiversité, c’est tout cela.
Pour vous l’expliquer,
on va continuer avec des photos.
Je reviens sur Justine Dupont,
sur une vague géante à Nazaré.
Vous avez sûrement déjà vu des images.
On est sur des vagues qui dépassent
des tailles de plus de 20 mètres.
Comment se forment les vagues ?
Généralement, les vagues
se forment grâce au vent.
Imaginez, vous avez une assiette à soupe.
La soupe est un peu trop chaude,
vous soufflez, des ridules se forment.
L’océan, c’est pareil à grande échelle.
Le vent, qui souffle très fort
sur des grandes distances,
transmet son énergie à la surface et
cette énergie se transforme en fréquence.
En sinusoïde.
Cette fréquence est
ce qu’on appelle la houle
qui se propage dans les océans
et qui, lorsqu’elle arrive près
du littoral ou près d’un récif,
se dresse un peu comme un cheval qui
se dresse et d’un seul coup, elle déferle.
Lorsqu’elle déferle, la houle,
c’est une vague.
Là, vous avez une vague géante.
Il y a des endroits où la houle
est beaucoup plus grande,
beaucoup plus grosse
qu’à d’autres endroits.
Les fonds sous-marins aussi ont
une importance sur la façon de déferler.
Il y a plusieurs facteurs
qui rentrent en compte.
Voici un autre type de vague.
Je parlais de l’empereur de Chine.
En Chine, au sud de Shanghai,
vous avez un mascaret qui déroule
dans le fleuve Qiantang.
C’est quoi, un mascaret ?
C’est une vague qui se
forme par les grandes marées.
Rien à voir avec le vent.
Quand la Terre, la Lune et le Soleil sont
alignés, se forment les grandes marées.
Lorsque certaines rivières
qui ont une forme d’entonnoir
permettent la création d’un mascaret,
il y a une vague qui rentre et qui remonte
le courant dans cette rivière.
Celui de Chine est l’un des plus puissants
et un des plus grands au monde.
On l’a appris récemment,
mais il y a toute une culture
historique autour du mascaret.
L’Empereur de Chine, au 7ᵉ siècle, avait
fait construire un palais sur les berges
pour observer le mascaret.
On a découvert récemment qu’il y avait
une pratique appelée Nong Tchao,
« le jeu de la marée » : des soldats
se jetaient dans la rivière.
Ils étaient décrits les cheveux détachés,
tatoués, avec une bannière -
une sorte de drapeau.
Ils attendaient la vague pour l’attraper
et aller le plus loin possible
avec cette vague.
On sait que, jusqu’au 13ᵉ siècle,
sous l’empereur Tsong du Sud,
ils utilisaient des planches
en bois en forme de poisson.
Incroyable ! Il y avait toute une culture
autour des vagues, avec une foule de gens.
L’empereur de Chine gratifiait
ceux qui allaient le plus loin.
Tout cela a peu à peu disparu.
J’ai eu la chance de le surfer en 2007
avec plusieurs surfeurs internationaux.
Depuis, les autorités
organisent de nouveau
des compétitions de surf sur ce mascaret.
Il y a un festival qui attire
des centaines de milliers de personnes.
Donc c'est étonnant.
Il y a toute une culture surf autour
du mascaret qui est en fait ancestrale.
Je reviens sur les Caballitos de totora.
Désolé pour la prononciation ;
le chinois, l’espagnol,
je ne suis pas forcément le meilleur.
Ce sont des embarcations qui
sont faites en roseau au Pérou.
C’est utilisé depuis plus de 3000 ans.
Il y a des sculptures, des écrits, des
dessins qui prouvent que, depuis 3000 ans,
les pêcheurs, notamment les pêcheurs qui
vont en mer chercher les éponges de mer,
utilisent ces embarcations
faites de roseau.
Lorsqu’ils reviennent vers la côte,
ils prennent les vagues,
ils surfent les vagues,
soit assis, soit debout.
En fait, on se rend compte que le surf
est une pratique très ancienne.
On pense tous que c’est né en Polynésie.
En effet, au 18ᵉ siècle,
les Occidentaux ont découvert
que les Polynésiens pratiquaient le surf
avec des planches de surf,
des codes, des règles.
Ils avaient réussi à dompter les vagues.
On appelait ça le sport des rois
et le roi des sports.
Mais en fait,
partout où il y a des vagues,
les êtres humains ont essayé
de les apprivoiser,
à croire que c’est quelque
chose d’universel.
On avait un autoportrait de Paul Gauguin ;
voici un de ses tableaux.
Ça, c’est près de chez moi,
dans une crique en Bretagne.
Deux cailloux, une petite vague
pas intéressante pour le surf,
mais ça a inspiré Paul Gauguin.
Le tableau est
aux États-Unis actuellement.
En fait, les vagues ont inspiré
beaucoup d’artistes,
des photographes, des cinéastes,
des poètes, des écrivains.
Les vagues sont aussi des sources
d’inspiration pour les artistes.
Rappelez-vous la dernière fois que
vous êtes allé au bord de la mer.
Rappelez-vous la dernière fois
que vous êtes allé à la plage.
Je suis sûr que vos 5 sens
étaient en éveil
parce qu’en effet, les vagues
mettent en éveil les cinq sens.
Tout d’abord, la vue.
Lorsqu’on arrive sur une dune ou sur
une falaise, c’est un véritable spectacle.
Le spectacle des vagues,
des monuments naturels qui dansent.
C’est très beau à voir ;
ça reste dans l’esprit.
Vous avez l’ouïe.
On l’a entendu, le son,
le chant des vagues.
Vous avez également l’odorat.
Quand on arrive en bord de mer,
on remplit ses poumons très fort
et vous avez l’iode qui rentre en vous.
On sait depuis l’Antiquité
que c’est très bénéfique.
Pas besoin d’être dans l’eau,
vous prenez un peu de l’océan
et des vagues.
Vous avez le goût.
Après un après-midi au bord de la mer,
ses embruns se déposent sur les lèvres.
Vous avez le goût de l’iode et du sel
lorsque vous passez votre langue dessus.
Si vous partez dans l’eau,
que vous passez sous une vague,
vous êtes en contact -
votre peau, l’épiderme directement -
avec les vagues, l’océan, le milieu marin.
Quand on en ressort, c’est comme si
la journée recommençait une 2e fois.
C'est comme une renaissance.
Les vagues éveillent les cinq sens.
Pourquoi ? Peut-être car
la vie est née dans les océans.
Avant de coloniser la terre, nous sommes
forcément tous passés par les vagues,
il y a très, très longtemps et
c’est peut-être dans notre instinct.
Je suis spécialisé dans l’exploration :
je recherche des vagues
dans des endroits inconnus.
J’ai été dans des endroits
comme la Libye, l’Algérie.
J’ai surfé en Albanie, en Chine,
à Haïti, à Cuba, en Sierra Leone.
J’ai adoré aller dans les îles Turtle,
avec l’ethnie des [?], au Gabon,
aux îles Comores, plein d'endroits.
Voici un exemple de l’un de mes
derniers voyages en Ouganda.
Les vagues sont modestes, mais surtout
il n’y a pas la mer en Ouganda.
Mais c’est le deuxième plus grand lac
au monde, le plus grand d’Afrique,
plusieurs fois la taille de la Bretagne
ou de la Belgique.
Lorsque le vent souffle,
des petites vagues se créent
et les pêcheurs font attention aux vagues.
Ils prennent la mer en fonction
de la météo et des vagues.
Il y a une culture autour des vagues,
même à 1200 m d’altitude,
car il est très élevé, ce lac, sur
l’équateur, très très loin des océans.
Ça fait partie de l’hydrodiversité aussi.
Lorsque je pars en voyage et
que je reviens en France chez moi,
je cherche à transmettre
ce que j’ai vécu, à le décrire
via des articles, des écrits, des livres,
parfois des vidéos, parfois des photos,
parfois des reportages.
À force de les décrire, je me suis aperçu
que chaque vague avait une identité,
un ADN.
Lorsqu’on est surfeur,
on entretient presque un dialogue
avec l’océan et avec les vagues.
On leur donne presque une personnalité.
C’est ça aussi, l’hydrodiversité.
Ces vagues sont importantes
pour les surfeurs, bien sûr,
mais ça reste du divertissement.
Mais d'abord, les vagues sont très
importantes pour l'environnement.
Elles viennent oxygéner le milieu marin.
Il y a beaucoup de vie dans les vagues,
sous les vagues, sur les vagues.
Elles retournent le sable,
font sortir des coquillages
qui attirent des poissons, des oiseaux.
Il y a toute une vie,
c’est très important.
Ici, un orque qui utilise la force
des vagues pour se hisser sur le sable,
attraper sa proie et repartir
avec le backwash, le ressac.
Toute une technique grâce aux vagues,
avec les vagues.
Les gens qui connaissent les tropiques
savent que dans un atoll,
autour d’une barrière de corail,
les zones exposées à la houle
sont plus oxygénées.
Il y a plus de corail,
il est beaucoup plus dense,
beaucoup plus développé.
Donc c’est très, très important
pour l’environnement, l’hydrodiversité.
Mais aussi, par exemple, dans les années
30, lorsqu’il y a eu les congés payés,
les Français ont commencé à découvrir
de plus en plus leur littoral,
les bains de mer, et donc les vagues.
Il y a tout un tourisme
qui existe depuis presque 100 ans :
venir observer les vagues à Biarritz, à
Quiberon, à la Torche, à Nazaré, à Hawaï,
Beaucoup d’endroits.
Tout ça, c’est une économie.
Il y a une vision économique
des choses autour des vagues.
Les sports de glisse, l’industrie
du surf, les combinaisons,
la crème solaire, le tourisme
du surf et des sports de glisse.
Peut-être que demain
on fera de l’énergie aussi,
hydrogène ou électricité, avec des
fermes à vagues, des fermes houlomotrices.
C'est en expérimentation.
Mais malgré tous ces bienfaits
qu’on a pu voir pour les vagues,
de nombreuses sont menacées.
De nombreuses ont disparu à cause de
l’artificialisation [d’origine humaine] :
les enrochements,
les endiguements, les ports,
les digues, le dragage du sable.
Par exemple, dans le Pays basque,
à l’embouchure de l’Adour,
il y avait une vague mythique
appelée « la barre ».
Dans les années 60, les gens venaient
de partout pour surfer cette vague.
On a agrandi le port de Bayonne
via deux digues
et la vague a disparu pour toujours.
Voici un spot connu en Espagne,
qui s’appelle Mundaka,
considéré parmi les plus
belles vagues d’Europe.
Il y a 20 ans, on a pompé tout le sable,
300 000 m3, pour le déplacer
sur une autre plage.
La vague a disparu alors que les
championnats du monde se passaient là-bas.
Ça a été un choc pour les locaux.
Ils ont décidé de réagir.
Heureusement, le sable s’est reconstitué,
la nature a réinstallé la vague
et ils ont créé une réserve de vagues,
un périmètre où on décide
de préserver les vagues.
C'est un outil de préservation.
Ces deux, trois dernières années,
on a tous eu un peu plus de temps.
J’ai eu un peu plus
de temps pour m’occuper,
me pencher sur les vagues autour
de chez moi plutôt que d’aller très loin.
En Bretagne, en France.
En cherchant un peu, je me rends
compte que la France est
la championne du monde
de l’hydrodiversité.
La 2e plus grande aire maritime au monde :
11 millions de kilomètres carrés,
avec des territoires en Polynésie,
dans les Terres australes antarctiques,
aux Antilles, en Méditerranée,
à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon,
autour de Madagascar, les îles Éparses
et bien sûr, Tahiti, Nouméa.
La France est presque partout,
et c’est une diversité exceptionnelle.
Je me suis dit qu’il était important
de mettre en avant cette hydrodiversité.
J’ai donc décidé de créer une association
pour promouvoir et préserver ces vagues,
notamment chez moi,
à Saint-Pierre-Quiberon.
J’ai approché la mairie.
Je leur ai proposé de créer la 1e
réserve de vagues en France.
On a créé un dossier, on a eu
un vote au conseil municipal.
Ça a été adopté
et déclaré d’utilité publique.
Pour la 1e fois en France, on reconnaît
l’hydrodiversité comme étant légitime
et à préserver.
(Applaudissements)
Je vais avoir une petite anecdote
autour du lion.
Ça n’a rien à voir, mais en fait si.
J’étais en Afrique, en pleine brousse,
très loin de la mer.
Il fallait passer dans la forêt.
Sur la piste, il y avait
un check-point avec des militaires.
Ils nous arrêtent - il y avait
une barrière - et ils nous disent -
j’étais avec des amis surfeurs :
« C’est quoi sur le toit de la voiture ?
- Des planches de surf.
- C’est interdit. »
Ok, c’est interdit.
On va au poste,
ils prennent nos passeports,
ils commencent à être un peu
intimidants, ça prend du temps.
Je vais voir le plus gradé des militaires,
je lui explique.
Je sors les planches de surf :
« C’est pour aller se mettre
debout sur les vagues. »
On était loin de la mer.
Il me regarde,
et là, il me dit : « Wahou ! »
Il commence à rugir.
C’est la puissance du lion.
Le surf, les vagues,
c’est la puissance du lion.
Ça a duré pendant deux minutes, j’étais
interloqué, je ne savais quoi dire.
Il tape sur l’épaule :
« Bonne route, mon ami. »
Il me rend le passeport
et nous laisse partir.
J'étais un petit peu surpris.
C’est un peu rigolo -
à la fois tendu et rigolo.
Mais je me suis dit :
« Il a entièrement raison. »
Les êtres humains se sont battus
pour faire disparaître les prédateurs,
comme les lions par exemple,
qui étaient très dangereux -
qui le sont toujours.
Maintenant qu’il n’y en a plus beaucoup,
il faut les préserver.
Ils sont au sommet de la biodiversité.
S’ils disparaissent, tout s’écroule.
Les vagues, c'est pareil.
Les vagues sont au sommet
de la pyramide de l’hydrodiversité,
donc c’est important de les préserver
pour les océans.
C’est important de respecter les océans.
Si on ne respecte pas les océans,
comme c’est notre reflet,
c’est qu’on ne se respecte pas soi-même.
Pour conclure,
je terminerai avec quelques alexandrins
d’un poème de Charles Baudelaire,
« L’homme et la mer. »
Homme libre, toujours tu chériras la mer !
La mer est ton miroir ;
tu contemples ton âme
Dans le déroulement infini de [sa] lame
Et ton esprit n’est pas
un gouffre moins amer.
Voilà.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)